la nouvelle salve de sanctions annoncées
ce lundi par la maison blanche vise 23
personnes et 21h organisation biélorusse
parmi lesquels on trouve le comité
national olympique de biélorussie une
sanction qui fait suite à la faire de
cet athlète biélorusse aux jeux
olympiques qui a affirmé être victime
d'une tentative de rapatriement forcé
washington qui affirme par ailleurs que
ce comité national olympique de
biélorussie est coupable de faciliter le
blanchiment d'argent
parmi les autres entreprises ciblées par
ces sanctions américaines il y à la
société bayrou skalli qui produit de
l'engrais en biélorussie et entreprises
qui figurent sur une liste que
l'opposante biélorusse vers cannes a dit
khan of sky a affirmé avoir donné aux
autorités américaines c'était il ya
moins de deux semaines lors de sa visite
ici dans le pays rappelez vous elle
avait été reçu à la maison blanche par
le président américain s'était 28
juillet dernier
s'il s'agit d'une rencontre très
importante d'un message adressé au monde
entier que le plus grand pays du monde
est avec nous et cette rencontre est
comme la victoire de tous les
biélorusses qui se battent dans l'autre
sens c'est en quelque sorte une
inspiration pour notre peuple pour aller
de l'avant ne pas abandonner
même si les gens n'abandonne pas assez
certain mais c'est un signal
supplémentaire que nous avons des alliés
forts à nos côtés mais ça et das le
soutien affiché de joe biden pour cette
opposante biélorusse ainsi que ces
nouvelles sanctions ou pour but
d'accroître la pression autour du
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko
washington qui réclame l'organisation
d'une nouvelle élection présidentielle
en biélorussie alors de son côté le
président biélorusse a réaffirmé ce
lundi sa victoire et dénoncer ce qu'il
présente comme un coup d'état organisé
par l'opposition dans le pays minsk qui
fustige très régulièrement les positions
des pays occidentaux les états unis en
tête et ans à qui il reproche notamment
leur proximité avec des
figure d'opposition en biélorussie et
d'être derrière un certain nombre de
manifestations qui se sont déroulées en
biélorussie ces derniers mois ces
sanctions annoncées ce lundi par
washington font suite à d'autres
sanctions qui avait été prononcée au
mois de juin dernier après l affaire de
ce vol ryanair qui a qui s'était posé en
biélorussie notez enfin que les
premières sanctions américaines à
l'égard de la biélorussie remonte déjà à
2006 et à l'époque le président s'était
de georges d'hollywood